everybody please welcome Gary well my
wife and I just recently got married
she's perfect she's everything I ever
wanted and you know I'm having a little
tiny bit of trouble bonding with my new
stepson Lucas whoa look at that Sam
samarth worms good talking to you buddy
never really looks me in the eye doesn't
talk much except when he yells at me to
get out of his room turns using this
weirdo puppet thing I get this sense
that he's that he's evil incarnate yeah
remind me again how Lucas was conceived
you remember when I told you about that
crazy time in my 20s where I joined this
sort of like oh no I think you told me
about that big doomsday cult believed a
child will rise up from hell to rule
mankind and to bring on the end of the
world as we know it I think we found
that child and now you're his stepdad
there is nothing wrong with Lucas he's
very
he do this to me you told me that was
normal that all kids are dick that's
true kids are dicks man but this is the
sentient level
he's like top of the dick chain bro
[Music]
ah
[Applause]
this is dude bro you gotta relax man I
relax we're in a cornfield so what good
thing has ever happened in a cornfield
al I don't know Field of Dreams is
pretty cool
[Applause]
you